HE DID SAY WHAT HE SAID ANY
APOLOGIZE BUT WE APPRECIATE YOU
COMING ON THE SHOW, WE
APPRECIATE YOU ANYTIME.
NOW FOR THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
COIN, SOUTH CAROLINA REPUBLICAN
SENATOR TIM SCOTT JOINS US.
SENATOR SCOTT, YOUR COMMENTS ON
THE CONGRESSWOMAN’S REACTION.
>> WELL WHITEWASH IS ARROGANT,
SENSITIVE, PAINFUL COMMENT THAT
HE MADE.
IT TELLS ME THAT HE HAS TAKEN
THE BLACK VOTE FOR GRANTED AND
HE WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO.
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME WE
HAVE HAD RHETORIC FROM THE
VICE PRESIDENT THAT HAS BEEN
OFFENSIVE.
FACTUALLY, LISTEN TO MY GOOD
FRIEND CONGRESSWOMAN FROM TEXAS,
THIS IS WHAT WE SHOULD THINK
ABOUT.
SENATOR KAMALA HARRIS THAT
CALLED ATTENTION TO
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN IGNORANCE
ON THE ISSUE OF SCHOOL BUSING.
IT WAS SENATOR CORY BOOKER WHO
CALLED HIM ONTO THE CARPET FOR
THE CRIME BILL.
SO HIS RECORD HAS BEEN CALLED
INTO QUESTION BY HIS OWN PARTY.
THE THING I HEAR RIGHT NOW FROM
THIS PARTY, HOWEVER, CRICKETS.
IT IS QUIET AS A CHURCH MOUSE
RIGHT NOW ON THE LEFT.
I’M TIRED OF HEARING PEOPLE PUT
DEMOCRATS ON A PERCH WHEN IT
COMES TO OFFENSIVE, RACIALLY
OFFENSIVE COMMENTS AND THEY HOLD
REPUBLICANS TO A VERY DIFFERENT
STANDARD.
AT THE SAME TIME, THIS
ADMINISTRATION THAT HAS MADE
PERMANENT THE FUNDING FOR
HISTORICALLY BLACK COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITY FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
AMERICA’S HISTORY.
THIS ADMINISTRATION THAT IS
REVERSED THE DAMAGES DONE BY THE
1994 CRIME BILL WAS THE FIRST
STEP ACT.
THE PRESIDENT SIGNED THAT
LEGISLATION INTO LAW.
IT WAS PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THIS
ADMINISTRATION THAT DECIDED TO
WORK WITH ME AND OPPORTUNITIES
TO BRING $75 BILLION FROM THE
PRIVATE SECTOR INTO THE POOREST
COMMUNITIES IN THIS NATION,
CLOSING THE WEALTH GAP.
SO WHAT I’M SUGGESTING HERE COME
I WOULD LOVE, LOVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PUT RECORD VERSUS
RECORD BECAUSE IF WE DO THAT
COME AFRICAN-AMERICANS WILL BE
VOTING INDEPENDENTLY, SOME FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP, SOME FOR
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN.
>> Bret: SENATOR, TO THAT
POINT, JOE BIDEN DID APOLOGIZE
AND A PHONE CALL TO THE BLACK
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE THIS
AFTERNOON SAYING HE WAS TOO
CAVALIER.
HE WENT ON TO SAY, LOOK
DONALD TRUMP, THIS IS THE SAME
MAN WHO CALLED AFRICA AND ALSO
CLAIMING THERE WERE PEOPLE ON
BOTH SIDES IN CHARLOTTESVILLE AS
THEY CAME OUT OF THE FIELDS
CARRYING TORCHES.
HE LIED ABOUT PRESIDENT OBAMA’S
BIRTH CERTIFICATE AND FAILED TO
RESPOND TO RACIAL DISPARITIES IN
THE PRESENT CORONAVIRUS AND HAS
ADVANCE POLICIES THAT HAVE
THREATENED AFRICAN-AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES.
HE LEVELED A LOT OF CHARGES IN
THAT CALL, BUT IT IS A CALL IN
WHICH HE APOLOGIZED.
CRITICS TO THE PRESIDENT SAID HE
NEVER REALLY APOLOGIZED.
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
>> I WILL SAY A COUPLE OF THINGS
I’M NOT SURE OF THE DEFINITION
OF CAVALIER COMMIT MUST BE
ARROGANT.
THE DEFINITION OF CAVALIER MUST
INCLUDE PAINFUL.
THE DEFINITION OF CAVALIER AND
SPEAKING IN JEST I THOUGHT IT
MEANT OFFHAND, JUST A JOKE BUT
THIS IS A CONSISTENT LANGUAGE
USED OVER DECADES, NOT JUST NOW.
FIRST AND SECOND THING, WHEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND I HAD A
STRONG DISAGREEMENT OVER
CHARLOTTESVILLE, WHAT DID HE DO?
HE CALLED ME INTO THE
OVAL OFFICE AND HAD A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE RACIAL
HISTORY OF THE COUNTRY.
WHEN WE FINISH THAT
CONVERSATION, THIS IS WHAT HE
SAID.
TIM, HELP ME HELP THOSE I HAVE
OFFENDED.
WE WORK TOGETHER TO CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES OWN LEGISLATION,
PASSING IN A TAX BILL, AND
BECAUSE OF THAT, 31 MILLION
AMERICANS LIVING IN THE MOST
DEVASTATED PARTS OF THIS COUNTRY
ARE GOING TO BE RECIPIENTS OF
THE $75 BILLION COMING INTO
THEIR COMMUNITIES TO BRING MORE
ACCESS TO OPPORTUNITY, HOPEFULLY
BETTER ACCESS TO QUALITY
EDUCATION AND CERTAINLY AROUND
THE COUNTRY, WE ARE HEARING MORE
AND MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS THE KEY TO
SHRINKING THE WEALTH CAP.
SO WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
DONE, SIT DOWN AT A HAD A
CONVERSATION WHEN THERE IS A
CHALLENGE.
NOW I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO SIT
DOWN WITH HIM BECAUSE I WAS
OUTSPOKEN ABOUT HIS COMMENTS.
WHAT DO I HEAR FROM MY FRIENDS
ON THE LEFT?
NO ONE IN LEADERSHIP IS SPEAKING
OUT AGAINST VICE PRESIDENT
BIDEN.
NO ONE IS CALLING HIS COMMENTS
ON THE CARPET.
YOU CANNOT MAKE PROGRESS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP MADE PROGRESS
BECAUSE HE’S GOING TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION.
A PAINFUL CONVERSATION AND WE
WERE ABLE TO FIND A PATH
FORWARD.
NOT ONLY DO WE HAVE OPPORTUNITY,
BUT FUNDING OF HBCU AND SICKLE
CELL ANEMIA TOGETHER.
WE HAVE WORKED ON EDUCATION
TOGETHER.
THAT IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
HAVE A CONSTRUCTIVE
CONVERSATION.
WHITEWASHING VICE PRESIDENT
BIDEN’S COMMENTS ONLY MEAN HE
WILL CONSISTENTLY DISRESPECT THE